what do you like to say everybody here
things me thank you very much trying to
come home no apologies freshest yeah
okay okay just before I go on to the
minutes a couple of things to mention
one is that two of the items do have a
PLC
appendices if we want going to discuss
those we will need to go into P and C
but we haven't specifically put it up
here the section so please be wary to do
what's refer to those then we move into
PVC and secondly items 7 & 8 I'm going
to take the other way round so I'll take
item item 8 first and then from 7
because it makes more logical sense
you've all had copies of so may be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the building by the
nearest available exit there is one far
exit in this room if you need to
evacuate do so by the class door to the
external fire escape papyrus game
staircase please hold handrails in case
the stairs are still wet or slippery if
anyone is unable to use the stairs would
you please and others to exit the room
before they go to the fire escape when
where they can be given further
assistance assembly point will be the
public car park in Simon singing Suites
please do not delay evacuation
belongings please do not return building
tool giving permission to do so by
council staff please note that these
people
the audio recorded and can I please
remind you to switch off from our
basketball tournament assignments now
you all have copies of luminance of the
6th of November 2019
are you happy i side those now with
regards to the minutes of the 9th of
October portfolio Holger for planning
has asked if we filament minutes one aim
for the current paragraph reads
the portfolio planning to make the
officers for their hard work on
negotiations over several months he was
pleased that they this would help
facilitate the group of residents to
officially house with new premises like
to just event one part of it and for it
to read the portfolio holder for
painting the portfolio holder planning
commended officers for their due
diligence and hard work in respect of a
difficult legal negotiation over the
past month
are you happy that we amended
[Music]
right item four declarations of interest
questions or notice for councilors
matters refer to the executive reports
of different other committees there are
no which leads me on to deciding to
change around and we take back some
eight must Chapman I'm gonna kick off
and as I was sitting here it just
suddenly occurred to me that the
management team appears to be sitting in
the gloom of this end so I'm going to
travel down here into the light which in
the sciences is a bit like the journey
of the Canadian program I think so I'm
going to do a quick a quick PowerPoint
presentation it's not death by purpose
the purpose of this is is to try and
summarize as clearly as possible the key
principles of the of the connect program
so we can go into the next or the first
slide please so connect program the
council's corporate culture and
transformation program so you know this
is a big thing for the council we want
to look to see how we can move the
council forward from where we are now
and transform us into something fit for
the 21st century to be able to deliver
great services to our residents using
the latest technology so in sonar can
you read that I'm struggling to read it
so what we'll be doing the program will
encompass reviewing all of the council's
existing systems and that inevitably
will mean investment in new technology
and as members know there's been a lot
of investment in
in IT over the last couple of years
in any event but we want to be able to
give the workforce and members the tools
that you'll need to be able to to be
able to work closely with residents in
delivering services we need to engage
closely with staff and stakeholders and
establish a genuine two-way
communication throughout this process
we're going to have to carry staff with
this because it's going to need people
doing things in very different ways and
capitalizing and the opportunities that
come along as the as we as we discover
how the technology will be able to
assist us so and the end result of that
will be I think a pipeline of projects
that will bring back over a period of
time to members with business cases
fought for approval if I'm going to the
next slide so what will it achieve well
I've mentioned digital technologies and
the aim is for us to have better ways of
communicating with residents better ways
of delivering services for our residents
and you know I think that's something
that we all feel passionate and
enthusiastic about we're gonna have to
review all our systems that we change
these improvements to the way we do
things I can remember back in I think it
was probably May 2007 the first time we
actually proved planning applications
online and it was quite a revelation
because residents could actually go onto
the website and they could look at
planning applications in a way that
wasn't possible before and that meant
that actually many residents decided
that they didn't need to come to the
councils offices and actually speak to
speak to officers because they could get
the information
directly so that changed the way that we
actually delivered that particular
service and we've seen all sorts of
other changes taking place Syd since
then and you know the latest examples
being something like the housing choice
system that allows residents to to log
in and actually get information update
their own their own records so we're
seeing lots of changes in technology
taking place so what's crucial for us is
how how we reconcile all that with the
21st century way of delivering services
for members and the staff okay to move
into the next slide
so what do we need - why do we need it
well we need to modernize we need to go
along with what the technology
opportunities will provide for us if
some of you may have been at the end of
a room chair and Daniel and might were
at the the connect D that we had across
other operative Hill and we had a an
Alexa there for example and you know
people were fascinated about the
opportunity that that actually created
to ask about council services so you
know that's a sort of example of how
technology is changing the way that we
actually can deliver services but we're
going to have to equip our staff with
the knowledge and skills to be able to
do that and members are going to have to
be part of that journey as well so in
order to do that and deliver the best
customer experiences we're going to need
to communicate closely with our staff
talk about those those aspirations in a
way that is is positive and reflects the
changes in working practices and so on
and we move on so all of that's the
driving force behind the reasons we're
moving to cloud computing to give us the
flexibility to be able to deliver
services when we want where we want in
better and play
scible in flexible ways okay so some of
you will recall the local partnership
assumes review that took place of the
coop while ago that remain recommended
change management intervention through a
corporate change program and effectively
that's what we envisage the connect
program being move on so how will it
work well there are three proposed work
streams the service delivery digital
transformation so that's all about
looking to see what the opportunities
technology will give us to be able to
change the way that we deliver services
clearly we're going to have to look to
see how we can develop the the staff
because there will be training and
development required and you know the
culture of the organization is likely to
change as we move along because people
will be doing things in different ways
in different places and that means that
we're going to have to be on the top of
our game in terms of communication and
engagement both with all the staff that
with use as members as well so connect
program is key to how we deliver
services how we change the council in a
way that will ensure that we can reflect
the opportunities that technology will
give us over the over the coming years
so that's a starter for ten chairmen
development of cancer the rule counselor
after you want to chip in thank you
that's great and one thing I will say is
thank you for mentioning members in that
report I think members felt that the
actual reports come in to exact length
dimension members so to include this in
your presentation today thank you very
much for that and I'm very excited about
this project and I'm very hungry to get
it going and I know a lot of staff are
on site now but it didn't start like
that
I think dawn will remember that very
robust conversations that we had when we
first started talking about this and
rightly or wrongly I'm a sentimental
person and the thought of losing some of
our heritage which at the end of the day
that this building is and I was quite
concerned I'm quite worried about how
will they go forward but we had a robust
conversation for several and we work
around it and as I say I'm really really
passionate about this project and I
think since the connect day I think
we've got the staff on site certainly
ninety-nine point nine seven four mile
resided there couple that were a little
bit uneasy a little bit worried but you
know we're all going to be people this
journey of ours now with my job I
actually go into southern Borough
Council quite frequently and I have to
say when I first started going in there
some 12 years ago it was very dire very
time to develop
and I've opened it up and they made it
or pretty colors and you know something
that we want to do in our buildings and
I think that's very welcoming so we
don't have we don't want to particularly
have a reception we want to have it
welcoming we want our council to be
welcoming so yes I'm really excited and
I think I don't know where the psalmist
would agree with me but I think I've
been the money well spent
we're certainly needs giant stomp and
it's pointed in the right direction
there will be lots of workshops we know
it's been a while and this hopefully
week the culmination of going into the
cloud of a lot of things that we put in
place before this will be what Greens
know in the staff might let job easier
so one feel like hopefully once we like
come into a job for lunch it's a place
you're gonna be still you work and you
can work from home also I think it
helped us retain staff because they have
better ways of working and I think you
helped us in probably better stuff but
it's not always about the money we want
to be the best funky council that there
is in the area and we're gonna get the
best off because they're going to enjoy
working here this dovetail with some
other projects we've got so that's good
also this will bring this staff training
up into a point as well which was
alluded to in the
we knew we had people here so that
hopefully would look at that and just
make stuff feel more confident in what
they're doing and that's brilliant
hopefully we'll get is coming forward
thank you Jim the the necktie was was
very successful when I think I believe
we're having another one
now is it okay to invite the exactly
members to that do we think or is it
something that you just want to keep to
myself and I personally think it would
be good to invite members certainly I
mean what are the things that occurs to
me in all this is that you know the way
that services may change in the way that
access to services may change as part of
this program will be is an advantageous
to to members as as it will be to
officers to be able to deliver services
to residents because you know the
likelihood is that you'll be able to get
you know access to more information that
will give you you know a different sort
of perspective in terms of the way that
you are ready to are able to deal with
residents and residents queries and so
on I think that the only word of caution
I would have about saying well could we
just invite the exec to connect these
that that that's just a subset of the
members so I think I think can we can we
have a bit of a think about how that
might work because I'm from my
perspective I think it's important that
we take you know all members of the
council along on the journey so I just
need to find a way of ensuring that it's
inclusive I suppose I'm worried about we
we've just got stopped on board and if
you have
to attend we forget 39 members is that
gonna be are they going to be frightened
to asking certain questions I was
thinking about because the it's really
important about the narrative and the
messages that are the start are going to
be receiving the last connected today we
did was about the different work streams
that we have here to explain that to
them and then that did some
conversations around how we were with
the asset delivery program and the next
one we're going to do is hopefully
sometime in April when they are City
live trading great a point where we'd be
able to give some more information outs
of what we want the connect days could
be really both value to the start I
don't want to keep repeating what we're
doing and I I did think about whether
what we would do then is like a mini
connect day before members so that you
can hear the same message that their
staff would be receiving so I mean not
as you say you know stuff make me be
restricted in everywhere walk 39 members
or you know I feel quite so comfortable
but you know I was thinking about maybe
having the mini Connect days for many so
you really understand the messages in
the narratives were stolen from actually
being communicated to so we do them sort
of you know just after we've done the
connect days with staff so that any
queries any questions or anything off
your hearing style saying certain things
you're hearing the same message and the
narratives are really important for that
as well they don't know whether they
could work
I think for those since that way to
suffer that's a big eye-opener and I
just think you know I mean that was
amazing the way that that office
well those offices but and the
atmosphere when he walked into the
council offices was as I feel when I go
in Borough Council I think perhaps he
might be important for the yet to come
along to the staff team it's an
opportunity for the exec members to meet
to staff I must do it when we had a long
time long before I was able to sit and
talk to a lot of the stuff that we don't
normally see in the office the woodlands
team the guys that look after the
cemetery and you know those who think so
it's an ideal opportunity for the
executive especially you meet those
members of staff and I would recommend
that and then perhaps as the suggestion
of having a separate anyone for members
I think would be as advantage because
members will be able to ask questions
freely and of course it won't put
pressure or the staff where we need to
mention that the same time so when the
in fact I was out of the exact
their bodies to go into the members for
the mini connector that we have because
you are going to get as Sean has
correctly picked up you are going to get
them enough cigar now we don't want a
scenario in this project I know the the
feedback from having stepped over there
his leader of deputy leader to the
connect days was witty that have been
the feedback for me the staff was saying
how they like the fact that the
leadership team and you know yourselves
were there and they felt very joined
army but the messages were coming
through and they were types of messages
and so and the peer review also so that
we connect the model of that doing those
connect days it felt to them in the
feedback was
catwalk
thank you very much attention yeah I
mean I honestly believe that we really
do is most important as far as I'm
concerned I CT my team within within the
council it is so vital for every single
department that it works well and then
it serves a purpose and again obviously
going forward where we're going to need
to look at it not only with the
technology but also a holistic view
because if we're going into a new
environment and of course a lot of
people are going to be watching to take
their personal workspace with them and
of course that's not going to be
possible but what you have to create is
an acceptable workspace that everyone
will enjoy and feel comfortable in even
though they are going to be in a
temporary space but that space they will
feel comfortable in I believe you know
the support that we need to give
financially is absolutely primary for
the whole council a whole council
because I'm looking within my own own
division with regard to planning it's
it's vital that we have good
communications we have really good
quality of workflow that comes in
because we can't have downtime we can't
have the the past problems that we've
had but that's not just within planning
I guess it's within all the various
divisions you know to be able to do your
work effectively and efficiently you
need to be able to have this great
connectivity I guess that's where you
won't come from to connect a comic
tivity that is ongoing and so you can
respond quickly as a glad that bouncing
around did makeup she took the point
that then I had mine earlier on and I
think anyone echoed this with regard to
in the original report there was no
there was no member mentioning and and I
felt that that was a disappointment
within that and I see that in in the
slideshow you have no rectified that and
put down I think that's very important
because I mean from the example we had
to be Suffolk where we could see that
there was a genuine working together
between members and officers there was a
dream coming together when there was a
good conversation that was ongoing
concerns how they could be rectified and
what the hell we could go forward I
think that's that is the way forward in
my opinion and to be honest I fully
fully support what we're going to do
financially after this I think this is
so worthwhile
we what we have to carry on and I are
fully supported thank you gentlemen
certainly a part of this is the work
that the senior leadership team has been
doing led by Matt Holliday in terms of
providing premises but at the end of the
day buildings are nothing without people
it is people that make our business you
may think that I'm being a touch
pedantic but I would like to see a
capital S for staff on your presentation
it was capital M for members and I'd
actually like to see it swung around
capital S for staff or first staff and
members and if we can work in there for
the benefit of residents and businesses
in that roster because this is not about
any single spread it is about collective
working on making it efficient so how
buildings are important I hope that our
staff are being engaged at an
appropriate time about how the building
is laid out how it works and we have a
genuine consultation it isn't a top-down
approach it is taking people with us so
that they feel part of it and you
mentioned Sean it's about IT systems
leading our processes and operations I
would actually be a touch pedantic but I
believe it's about
having a vision in the light of what I'd
see there is out there and then making
sure that we are using IT not to be a
slave of IT but actually to make it work
to fulfill the vision that we have to
make us the best and these sorts of
words are becoming out from all sorts of
local authorities but I think we've got
to have a vision without supporting that
vision and of course principally the
people and I do think some of it is
about transforming jobs
it is about these killing jobs multi
skilling people so it provides variety
and interest for people it's looking at
working practices working smarter than
perhaps we currently do and it is a
tremendous credit to the relatively few
staff there are in this Authority the
tremendous amount of work that they
already do but there is opportunity to
with the use of technology to make it
even better so I really welcome and like
others I know that she's focusing on
transformation of the processes but I am
really excited there was a huge
opportunity for us 2020 marks an
exciting start especially for this new
kid on the block who was only elected
that way but it provides a huge
opportunity moving forward to make
really put rockford on the map and be
excited about how to shoot in essex for
busy season and people thank you
first of all it is to seek the approval
of our defense
transformation program
rekka one it is refunding 293,000 a set
aside a set out in the outlined business
case we funded from designating reserve
to be created from 2009 to 20 and
dispense that does it make the
programmers a gold project and as such
the dream that the investment board will
receive regular program updates to be
aligned with the asset delivery programs
and is everybody in agreement with a
moving back to seven well as a huge
willow and there was the now Minjae in
just a minute but I'm getting to quite
enjoy presenting some of these chords
reports because they are reflecting the
the excellent financial management that
we have of our funds and quite nicely
within under item one the decision being
recommended there are really four items
in there where there are new projects
that were able to promote and support
one of which because it was just the
last item with 293 thousand pounds been
able to be allocated to it so so it's a
nice place to be right now not to be
complacent about the future about it but
it's the right now we're talking about
at this meeting so I'll hand over to
allow me to give you a little bit more
of the detail just before you come in I
mean can I just point out that in light
of 1.2 it does say
you dropped along here somewhere so
pennies on sale so big now she was an
amendment to the Gentiles thank you I
know I'm in trouble
and yes it's councillor Smith said this
is the important three position so the
the yesterday other end of December 2000
19 20 and yeah the position says the
report our position in terms of the
revenue budgets and the capital position
as well and also the the latest
performance indicators about that date
and the overall position for their
accounts always positive as cancellous
methylated too and the over 1 to spend
that we're projecting for the current
financial year is 571 thousand pounds
which is a small increase from the
course of reposition and the majority of
that is due to staff savings which in
the most case is due to higher and then
expected and vacancy rate or post being
held with bacon during that during the
year as I've said at previous executive
meetings we are operating that a nearly
full establishment now there will always
be some element to turnover but
basically if we have recruited to
another number of the posts which were
being held vacant so we're not expecting
their position to be such high on spend
next on actual year in addition there is
a few other areas where we have made
some additional income in
year so in relation to planning fees and
great to turnover of parking in commerce
generated some extra extra income as
well so yes overall a positive a
positive position and that as I said a
number of recommendations about how we
might want to use some of that under
spending short term to sports and the
council's objectives so the connect
connect area which we just spoke about
and 20,000 pounds we're proposing to use
to help address the planning application
but luckily in the short term which
which should hopefully bring us back on
a more even keel and also 60,000 pounds
to extend and to fix time posts within
measure services which will help deliver
a number have put up projects over the
coming year and inclusion including
legal project which is activities and or
status meetings such programs say about
the revenue position in terms of the
capital position there is a fairly
significant amount of slippage in terms
of their capital program for this year
is something that not acknowledged
previously I think we've been a bit over
optimistic in terms of possibly what we
might be able to deliver in year and we
have started a challenge process in
terms of the position that's going to be
reported to council next week in terms
of next year's capital program but also
year-end in terms of challenging any
requests to carry forward monies to make
sure laying that they really are
deliverable and one specific request we
are putting forward in this report is to
substitute monies which were originally
set aside to reap acure a new financial
vendor system which we're not in a
position to progress at this time but
can be utilized effectively to put
towards a new customer relationship
management system so I'm recommending
the executive approves that that money
is three designated towards that
particular point
which will be able to be spent this this
financial year I won't go through the
performance indicators in any detail but
many members have got particular
question so much rice and electronics my
concern that we seem to keep mentioning
I'm starving
there are certain members of the council
that feel that we are understaffed and
that concerns me because I don't
actually believe we are and I ask
chairman does as well at our leadership
meetings you know if any AG feels they
need any staffing adjustments then there
needs to put me in the business case to
my management director and and it will
be looked at but you know I do get
concerned and I'm very jumpy when we
keep mentioning underspending staffing
because as far as I'm concerned you know
a few years ago before we had the change
in this council today were far too many
staff sitting there twiddling their
thumbs and I think we've got this just
about right now and I think there are
areas that maybe just need a little bit
we can still
a lot of branch on I'm sure I mentioned
directories if the idea is between the
necessary businessman business case so
you know I urge you that if you do have
concerns and issues come and talk to me
find me if you don't want to speak to
Sean first talk to me and I'll listen
[Music]
question on oh yeah
fingers 27000 you've managed to save an
audience is that why would they be on
the audit as staffing costs 23,000 then
best the audience stuff not a better
question the other night when the audit
whether people do an internal audits
they were so so yeah I mean Lord if he
hasn't actually been find their greets
and at this point in the year but that
will be presented back to audit
committee obviously that has been some
concerns about the external auditor and
so this so yeah there will be some loss
challenge about any additional fees that
they may or may not choose I think they
want me to charge up section if we're
late and stuff yeah I mean there's an
established process and you know an
opportunities challenge and review with
the public sector appointments and port
as well if we feel that the charge
that's they are asking for is on phase
unfair but this isn't particulars about
our internal audit function and the fact
that we have our chief auditor for and
buzz aldrin and I mean that that's
positive news story because we visit the
stock you know a certain number of hours
that would be required but they've been
charging off something as and when and
basis so effectively we're just being
charged for the service that we are we
are using slaps delived a bit of saving
process thank you glad just to pick up
on customer there that with regards to
the auditors they have for one of the
been afraid to be messiness about
has that caused us to have any
additional costs and because they'd be
messing about will we be getting a
reduction in their costs because they'd
be honest they haven't performed and
well I can't guarantee of certainty that
the actual fear itself will be reduced
although we have being raising this as a
sex white issue with colleagues across
assets and we just recently had a
meeting with the public sector
appointments and liaison officer for the
region and expressed our concerns about
the number of delays ER has been but it
is sort of industry-wide problem it's
not just either BYU our auditors or you
know a particular issue with a
particular audition for example is it's
a sector wide problem and that they are
aware that it needs to be addressed
I think the fees that were charged where
I set out within a framework and they
underwent a procurement and a couple of
years ago which set the sort of
framework for fees for the next few
years so there's limited opportunity to
sort of renegotiate those at the moment
but to say we would challenge strongly
as they were trying to charge additional
fees for example there hasn't been any
direct additional cost but obviously
it's about resourcing and time that's
been lost in terms busting out the plan
and I work within the finance team
obviously that has a knock-on impact in
terms of some of the other work we've
been able to do but I don't
it's necessarily involved in more direct
additional cost right so to push the
point where has there been any
additional costs because of the delays
our starting costs as the beaming off we
haven't secured words we haven't got any
additional staffing for example to cover
we've managed within our it's a series
nobody's even in their own time yes but
yeah there's a time the energy Lewis
possibly I'm saying there's no
additional direct cost part that has
been a cost in terms of officer time and
any delays yeah yes so we'll be looking
to them well as I said we are you know
in a process I don't actually an
established would be they wouldn't
charge us yeah but where we are in
conversation with them about that and
obviously they'll be challenging back
they acceptable and indicative fair the
start of the year so if you make a
change to that yeah because it's an
unusual Cuban process because they're
actually appointed by government to us
are they
well we opted into our procurement
framework whereby PSA your on behalf of
another lot of local authorities but I
mean we chose opt into that because of
the savings that the framework delivered
and I think part of the problem is that
they were probably to our ambitions in
terms of the savings they did lovely at
the outset if you actually and so yeah I
think that's a part of the issue that
they probably went in a two-night price
to begin to notice as when they've been
lady arises to whether there's any roof
a little room there for some of our
additional costs in staffing target said
yes thank you very much general no it
was just on today's parliamentary
discussion on the spending round and the
spending review that went through
Parliament to die there were amendments
that were discussed which were thrown
out and basically I wondered if if there
was any view being taken in regards to
how the government are going to be
looking at our situation in regards to
the money we receive or don't receive
and how long we're going to maintain any
form of grant or support from local
government no it's been a Libra know I
think I've had think that sort
discussion
in its day but obviously as I mentioned
that the budget briefings during the
course of the year as part of the budget
report there is significant uncertainty
and I think that some of that sort of
indications about how the funding
between may work starting to emerge and
they've just published an initiative
allocations for the adult social care
part which obviously doesn't affect us
directly but we are expecting over the
next couple of months to get some
indication of how that funding regime
may work and that will definitely have
an impact on 2021 onwards I think I
think there was an emphasis to
overlooking that thank you needs as
opposed to looking at an allocation
january across the board day there is a
view that irrespective we are classed as
a very affluent area but we do actually
have pockets of of desperate need and
there was the concept if I can just
carry on with regard to how council tax
is is rised in as much as that some of
the poor areas in the UK have poorer
quality homes and they're only writing
and either A or B or C at best and so
the ability to collect tax is reduced as
opposed to maybe any area mark ourselves
which has quite a large predominance of
D A's and F's which raise a higher
quantum of tax but will some have areas
of need and it's just trying to discover
that balance and and this was the
argument that was going on in Parliament
today how that will be resolved I don't
know but you know I kind of feel
desperate with regard to the fact that
you know we do have serious area of
needs especially within Rochford whereas
we have that fluence as well and how
that will balance out the hell will be
able to draw down and attract attention
to that need that's really my question
are we going to try and put in a
yeah I think he thought of her and
needed to know and what you said it's
okay hugely complex error and the huge
number of factors that go into
determining what funding we actually gas
and the actual relative balance between
the council tax base which is obviously
not directly within our control but
gives us perhaps a relative advantage to
some other authority areas and how the
business rates pile is redistributed so
the relative need and resources so
that's the redistribution of the
business rights part so yes I think
you're right in that Roger is classed as
one of them up you know relatively
affluent areas and we obviously we're
not have don't have it upon a
deprivation indices for example so that
probably is one of the reasons why the
funding sentiment is likely to work
against us and that's what part reason
when we've been talking about negative
iris tree and that that funding is
likely to go down but will be reflective
of the fact that I'll need is relatively
less compared to our local authority
areas but in terms of how we lobby and
make government yes certainly Oxford and
the local government sector as a whole
has been making representations to
government and I think part of it start
the overall quantum for local government
as well as how it is actually
redistributed to us recommendations on
page 71 I'll go through them one by one
but they haven't workplace right and
what what call the three 2019-20 revenue
budget and capital position set out in
sections 3 and 4 and the detail in
appendices 1 to 4 very brilliant item
1.2 to approve that the 293,000 these
additional notes of the potential
projected under sled is is allocated at
the year-end to create a new reserved to
fund connect project costs which are set
out in the separate report to the
executive one by three to approve that
twenty thousand pound of the projected
under spent is allocated into a fund and
consult to help progress the current
backlog of planning applications really
well went forward to approve that sixty
thousand of the protected under spend is
allocated to the to fund the extension
which in fixed term posts these ledger
services in the community portfolio and
to end of to the end of March twenty
twenty one 1.5 to prove the substitution
of forty thousand pound of capital
budget originally earmarked for new
financial management system to a new
customer relationship management system
in 2019 of twenty lastly one point six
to note the light latest position and
the council's key performance indicators
are shown at appendix five thank you
very much
the enterprise was taking the lead on
this particular item of the sports
grounds Thank You chair I'm pleased to
bring this report to executive this
evening because what it does is it
proposes to grant at least for 28 years
to the Braley 10 sports and social club
which is located along the London Road
people really and they have been
operating there for 21 years so far and
they have a thousand registered members
and a demonstrable example of a
community use in what they do there and
that there are long for-profit
cooperative organization and if I go to
4.1 to just emphasize this once there
we're talking about the 28 year lease
and the reason for that is it gives an
organization some long-term insurance so
that they can actually plan for their
future however what there is is a rent
review every three years and a mutual
breakup clause after three years or on
every third anniversary thereafter from
commencement of the lease and
that would be subject to a six-month
notice period where our intention as an
authority would be to work with them if
indeed there were proposals to relocate
none of us sitting around this table can
really plan for what might happen in 10
15 20 years with any surety and that is
why that brake clause is there the tenon
there is responsible for the building
and the contents and indeed for the
repair and maintenance of the building's
they are and to come on to the print
evaluations have been obtained and the
buildings are actually owned by the club
but of course the ground is ours and you
can see there the graduation has been
put on it as six to eight thousand
pounds and but I think we've got to
think in terms of the lower figure
because we understand from an evaluation
the 8000 reflects the more the value of
the buildings as well and now
interestingly enough because they are a
community organization it is right and
proper and reflected in our own these
policy that we provide some sort of
discount what isn't particularly helpful
to us we're looking at the discount is
how much do we give them so if we look
at it in terms of an arbitrary 20% of
discounts on 6000 pounds that would take
us down to 4,800 pounds at the present
time they are paying five thousand
thirty eight pounds ninety six pence
curious figures little they are and so
that falls within the valuation figure
and to put some degree of formality on
the whole thing we're proposing that we
increase it by CPI which is
absolutely figure of 1.9% this year
which gives us a rental income of 534
Scott 7-0 so that is the report as it
sits what I'm keen just to do is ask
manpower would white in a few moments to
see where he has anything to answer that
but I would also like for the benefit of
this meeting to be sure that you're we
turn to the map the plan the area green
is of course the piece of land not
directly associated with the subject
tonight but of course is access to the
Sports Centre the the club and when we
considered the conveyance of that which
using the process at the moment we want
you to make sure that there would be
legal access rights in perpetuity
we understand it's being brought up to a
doctrinal standard so that if it is
adopted in the future by the highway
authority it makes those standards and
the repair of the services within that
Road our fall within the responsibility
of the owner and there is a clear
standard that they are expected to make
now that's important because clearly we
don't want to find that whatever reason
we can't get to our own piece of
complaint so it's important although not
particularly relevant to our decision
tonight so I hand over to Matt if you
want to add anything to a said energy to
be German and I think council is covered
most of the points I was gonna write it
thank thank you for that and I think
that Alice opposed would be to say at
the lease itself was negotiated with you
regard to the council's these policy
before that in detail on also the
disposal framework so it's it's within
the body make a few points on the second
point chairman I think and broad with
the company
most of regarding the access road in
their language and so with regards to
the access way it will be as we aware
it's part of a disposal and it will be
written into the transfer that the that
be released both with the land without
giving away too much sensitive
information I know the Football Club and
the developer has been engaging with
each other to you know just out courtesy
to each other any disruptions that may
happen with regards to developing that
site so they are in contact with the
developer on that but it will be
protected and the lease will be attached
to the German I don't know I'd have to
check that okay come to the other
question that had was around with the
adjacent development is coming forward
and the 106 Bremen that they were going
to provide a car park for the sports
club hopefully that won't be too long it
was come but who ultimately will be
responsible for the land
that copper actually as I understand
from within the land so it will form
part of the lease so the the nice will
be a full repairing the maintenance
makes including the compound all the
sports companies where they know in them
and so they are land that they will
picking up the many others it's the
question putting out no mean possibly
don't know the answer off home for
completeness of understanding of the
deal in terms of rates do they have any
teach together I don't know if I know I
will have to check it's possible that
they would someone will say I'll check
Thanks just one was that their
designation only a charity the challenge
I'm not sure it's a nice tie just
because there's a suppose it's possible
some sports clubs are around each other
space but I don't know or because of it
obviously
Joseph Smith that I'm sorry to wondered
if there's been over 90 percent
automatic discount on rates with the
potential of a twenty to thirty twenty
twenty percent down to our our decision
so perhaps we ought to qualify that
okay sleep tight Akon just a quick
clarification the access roads we as the
least release we're leasing to the
sports bar it's not in the race yes we
are and the car park we sign that the
developers talk into the sports club yes
so if they decide he taketh thing is
that they want to go somewhere else
would that all revert back to us don't
worry
so aside from the access way edge green
which by then making funny transfer to
the developer all the land edged in red
is still ours we still own the freehold
interest and we've still got access
through that exercise maybe 15 years
hope you'll be entirely but there's a
recommendation on page 9.1 tubing right
to 1.1 release the council on land
age in red on the map annexed as
Appendix one trading town sports from
social club who uses a sports ground and
social news Thank You Chan and if I can
take members to the council's priorities
which we print or perhaps
every single agenda 40.3 to maximize our
assets and this is an example of where
we have a piece of land that was
identified in the asset register and
really it stands very much as laid out
in the report it is a plot of land that
exists in create real growth in stem
bridge and the proposal is that we
dispose of the freehold interest it is
as simple as that
on this map which is to add anything to
it jerilyn thank you once again I need
to say that with follow the processes
set out in the disposal framework once
again seeking panyu Asians and and also
following our process say to dispose of
framework in the asset strategy wits set
so how we identify surface land how
we'll treat that help us suppose of it
so again just for the clarity in terms
of process before that it's as per this
vocal framework that council approved a
lot okay just to clarify this piece of
land and the benefit of Planning
Commission is that outline of or full
bathrooms it's for gem is boarding the
other questions okay it's important
there is a recommendation on page ten
point one
it's a 1.1 to agree the disposal of the
freehold interest of the land HT ring
and attach plan think it's one by a
tender process members I think that is
the
that is awesome